hey guys catching up on the week stories
with my man david pacman and i saw some
video here which we're gonna show you in
just a sec of syrian women who escaped
isis and ended up in a Kurdish
controlled area Kurds are an ethnic
minority that are in Turkey and it's
Syria that we really don't talk about
enough they're trying to fight for their
own state that's a whole other a whole
other topic but I thought this video is
pretty incredible because it shows you
the level of repression that people
especially women have to live with in
Isis control areas versus what happens
when they leave
so it's pretty incredible stuff I mean
literally shedding the clothes that Isis
forces them to wear and can actually be
themselves it's pretty much the most
human thing there possibly is - why
don't we see more of these images this
is this is powerful stuff well I think
there's probably two reasons and and
maybe even more but one of the reasons
is that it's it's maybe not happening
enough as we would like it to happen and
number two is that when it is happening
there's probably some level of fear with
regard to documenting and and sort of
divulging and spreading the this type of
media and that would be just for all the
reasons that you and I have discussed in
the past as to why fear is a very
effective way to control people so I
think that it's not happening nearly
enough and when it does happen it's not
always going to even make it to YouTube
yeah and that's why I wanted to do this
story because to me it just it was such
a obvious example of repression and you
know the the human desire to be free and
you're seeing it it seems to me that
more I don't know why women's rights
groups and gay rights groups aren't
speaking up more against Isis you know I
mean like we talked about this once
before just that it seems like all these
minority groups and these groups that
stand up for the other it seems that
they should be the ones talking about
what we should do about Isis and again I
don't know that we should do anything
maybe all other countries of the area
need to do more often we do things and
it just ends up worse but it seems like
the minority groups should be speaking
out everything there's this interesting
thing along those lines I a couple years
ago I did a media training with a LGBT
rights organization that I was going to
be doing some media appearances with and
I won't say which one it was just
because maybe they don't want it to be
public that this is how they do their
media trainings but there was a
discussion about never equating or
comparing the struggle for LGBT rights
to any other struggle in history and the
the logic of it that as I was told it
was
listen there may be parallels but you
don't ever want to speak for someone for
another groups battle that they fought
so we want to have our messaging around
LGBT rights stand completely on its own
with regard to the merits and I was sort
of taken aback by this because I think
it's absolutely important to point out
that the struggle for racial integration
or what what whatever struggle there is
it is of course its own struggle with
its own players but it's it's to me
silly to ignore that the forces often
fighting against equality actually are
in a sense United or are related so I
actually did not think that that was a
good approach yeah I have a feeling that
I know which organization you went to
because they asked me to do media
training to which I said no because that
does seem crazy like I can't be
controlled by anyone but yeah I agree
with you it seems like there are all
these awful forces that stand against so
many of the things that are good about
Western values and progressive values
and women's rights and gay rights and
income equality and things of that
nature so I don't I really don't
understand why you'd want to keep all
these groups kind of splintered I just
don't get it and I do understand that
you know whereas to analyze the example
I gave right which was the struggle for
racial integration in civil rights in
the 60s and the LGBT rights movement now
we know that there actually is a portion
of the more religious black community
that actually doesn't share support for
the LGBT rights movement and we saw the
California with the prop 8 vote so I
actually would that particular example
you you could conceivably make the
argument that actually the players in
the movements don't necessarily agree
but I think that's a completely separate
issue from whether we should be drawing
parallels between other movements and
movements that we see today and
absolutely what's going on with Isis
should be part of that right yeah that's
a really interesting point so final
thought on this so you know every time
we do an Isis story I bring it up you
know that we in America look you can
blame George Bush for going into Iraq
which then
ultimately led to Isis you could blame
Obama because he's been president for
six years he pulled out of Iraq which
everyone wanted us to get out of Iraq
let this vacuum now Iraq basically is
not a country really isn't a country by
any standard definition Syria is
crumbling Lebanon is teetering Jordan is
teetering what do you think we're
supposed to do I really I don't know we
talked about this almost every week and
we make things worse but it seems to be
at some point here Isis is starting to
become the new Nazis they're not even
hiding what their what their goals are
and at some point maybe we have to try
something different
yeah I it's so tough for me to think
about this because on the one hand as we
started to talk about Isis months ago
there's this obvious anybody who's
rational and sort of connected to the
history of the situation understands
that there is some responsibility that
the United States bears for creating
it's significant responsibilities let me
not understate it for creating the
vacuum in which Isis came to power no
doubt about it the question of on which
many people would disagree is how far
does that responsibility go in terms of
what we need to do going forward at some
point maybe it's okay for the u.s. to
say this is as far as it goes right so
is that the irony of sort of the liberal
position because I think most people on
the Left I think that's what they're
saying they're acknowledging Bush
started this thing Obama got us out
perhaps both screwed up in their own way
but at some point you just gotta cut it
and let it go and I understand that line
of thinking and I'm not saying we should
do anything I know that just today i
think they announced they're sending 500
more troops to train iraqis we know
that's not going to do much because it
hasn't been doing anything the last
couple years but i think this is where
liberals are sort of caught between like
having a principled stand on seeing some
really awful [ __ ] now knowing we can do
something about it
versus you know we don't want to be in
every part of the world and sometimes
you just gotta let it be so at a certain
at a certain point i think the line will
sort of have
be drawn and it may be twenty years in I
don't know I mean I hope that it's not I
hope there's resolution before it gets
to having to make that call but no
question about it yeah all right well
what do you guys think it's a big mess I
know we all agree on that but should we
be doing or should our allies in the
area be doing more is there anything
that can be done or do we just leave it
up to the Iraqis and the Syrians and see
what happens let us know your thoughts
in the comments right now